we've been continuing to follow all of
the different ways in which donald trump
is likely to be tied up
with lawyers legal fees potentially in
depositions
of possible criminal investigations and
so much more and more and more it's
likely to be
years and years of this and it's
conceivable that donald trump may soon
have to actually
answer questions about the rape
allegations against him
under oath and this relates to e gene
carroll you mem
may remember that e gene carroll
accused donald trump of having raped her
in a manhattan department store in the
mid-1990s
and when this became a story
in 2019 donald trump said
he never knew egyne carroll accused her
of lying
to sell a new book and added that she's
not
my type well now her lawyers have filed
a defamation suit against donald trump
and in fact
they filed that suit some time ago but
not much was happening
partially because donald trump was still
president of the united states
now this is actually moving forward the
uh explanation
of trump is president and this can't
move forward for the time being
because he's president and it would be
in some way damaging or
prejudicial for it to move forward that
is no longer a defense
and eg and carol's lawyers are looking
to
depose donald trump in this
defamation suit and an attorney for
trump
is not returning requests for comment
about
this particular case but it is
conceivable that in the next could be
six months could be 12 months could be
18 months
donald trump would actually have to
under oath answer
questions about the alleged rape
that eugene carroll says took place this
is not
the only case in which donald trump may
have to answer questions under oath
about an alleged sexual assault that
he's accused of
there is a similar defamation lawsuit
from summer zervos that's
again a name that may ring a bell she
was a contestant
on trump's reality show the apprentice
and back in 2016
zervos also accused donald trump of
sexual misconduct
saying that it took place in 2007
initially um when they were at a meeting
in new york
and then later he groped her at a
california
hotel when they were supposedly meeting
to discuss
job opportunities trump not only denied
that but also says zervos is a liar
and so zervos sued donald trump for
defamation in 2017.
similarly that did not really go
anywhere because donald trump was
president
at the time and there is again the
renewed belief that that may
indeed be moving forward soon now
um legal experts have said
that the idea of um
the interference that the justice
department ran for trump on a lot of
these cases while he was pre a president
is unprecedented and um
that that is not the way that any other
president has been treated
while in office but that while still
academically interesting is in the past
the question now becomes
are these cases going to move forward
and is trump even as a former president
going to be compelled to be deposed and
we don't know the answer yet but it will
be extraordinarily interesting to follow
and see
now if you just zoom out of this for a
moment
it is truly another indicator
of the two-tiered justice system that we
have that donald trump
it's not even at this point that trump
hasn't been held accountable
for any of the things that he's done
they've not been adjudicated
right even if you believe that you're it
and as
we all should that you are innocent
until proven guilty
there's no adjudications that are even
on the table because donald trump has
been able to avoid
even responding to these claims donald
trump
has not been deposed when it comes to
these complaints
and he's not been put under oath he's
not even had to step foot
in court for anything so it's just
another reminder that there really are
two justice systems and that having
power having money having friends in
high places having obviously
uh being in the most privileged position
of power that one could arguably be in
in the world as president of the united
states laws
only matter if there's somebody willing
to enforce them and one of the things we
learned
big picture from the trump presidency
is that the systems that the founding
fathers put in place
as checks and balances to a president
for a president against the president
relative to a president uh arguably
weren't strong enough
because as soon as you had a president
willing to
ignore and to flaunt his power
and to flout the norms and checks and
balances
nothing happened now you could make the
case well the problem isn't the system
the problem is that trump had the
republican party
um willing to help him avoid
consequences well
then that's just part of the problems
with the system the system should be
the checks and balances should be robust
enough
that you don't have to depend on a
weaponized
friendly republican party to keep
a republican president out of actually
um
having to face the allegations against
them so
that that's the way it is if you have
money and if you have lawyers who can
just
tie things up with paperwork you can
burden just about any system endlessly
and keep yourself out of harm's way and
as we see you come at trump and then he
may sue you and then if you try to sue
trump for defamation then he'll just
figure out a way to avoid being deposed
and a lot of this hopefully
was only because he was president we
will see
we will see i'm not like super
optimistic i have to say